yeah
thank you thank you thank you stop it
put on your shirts
why arrest a thief when he can turn over
a new Leaf it's a liberal Solution
that's hard to believe for stores
overrun by thieves New York city mayor
Eric Adams had veiled an ingenious new
plan to combat skyrocketing retail theft
cases cover everything in the store with
they call it the SF approach
actually it's worse Adam Adams wants to
install kiosks in stores that would
connect potential criminals to social
service programs
They're laughing before it even ends
the idea is to get them the help they
need before they ransack the joint
I know it makes sense right that's like
asking Brian stelter to sign up for
Weight Watchers when he's in line at
Arby's
probably not a bad idea
Adams is also proposing de-escalation
training for retail workers or something
we used to call groveling so rather than
enforce the law and prosecute
shoplifters many of them repeat
offenders the mayor's office seemingly
wants to solve the crime Problem by
assuming criminals hell-bent on stealing
will instead take the initiative and
Avail themselves to free resources via a
kiosk
it's the same logic behind most reform
if we don't punish criminals then maybe
they won't be criminals everyone assumed
when recidivists were released from
prison they just go home and be great
dads well that was one hell of an
assumption and it was wrong as well as
the lame replacement for police and
prosecution which used to be you know a
great crime deterrent and so these
responses aren't dealing with
criminality but changing the citizens
response to such criminality absence of
police which is now just acceptance just
imagine how these kiosks might work
thank you
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa sir excuse me
excuse me um I can tell you have no
intention of paying for the stuff allow
me to de-escalate this situation have
you heard about our social services
kiosk you don't need to steal any of
this stuff right now we offer a wide
range of shipping options so you just
tell us what you're going to steal and
then we'll send it to you later I can
tell you're not convinced but we also
have perks for our frequent shoplifter
such as yourself stock options
membership in our wine of the month club
can I sign you up
oh
can I get another kiosk look
excellent work on finding something that
is almost like a kiosk must have been
hard Joe uh I think you'd love a good
kiosk don't you I love to get good kiosk
straight that is that is true but what I
don't love is being embarrassed in
public and to me if someone stops me at
a store and says you've been shoplifting
will you look at this kiosk I'm not
going to wait around and be humiliated
like that I wear a false mustache when I
buy Activia
what I'm trying to say is like criminal
justice isn't just about Rehabilitation
it's about deterrence and Punishment and
I'm fine with the kiosks just just the
kiosk should be located in jail
[Applause]
the turns the kiosk should pop up an
outcome a machine gun and it was just
shoots the guy in the head you think
that's a little strong
yeah yeah you think so yeah okay
um I don't okay so teaching them how to
de-escalate will not solve the issue of
why anyone would want to do that right
if you you know to maybe put yourself in
a threatening situation to I don't know
make your employer happy that probably
pays you like minimum wage if you work
at you know it's not like a Duane Reade
or you work at you know something like
that it's not your business and I don't
think anyone out there is committing
crimes because they just haven't been to
the right kiosk yet
this has got you know it kind of makes
me feel bad about
uh prison reform Aaron because I thought
like I bought into the idea that there
were all these kids without their
fathers right they all went to that was
the whole argument you lost a generation
of dads but there was this faulty logic
that the assumption that they were all
going to come out and just not commit
crime so we let people out and then they
committed more crime it's kind of the
same kind of Wishful Thinking do you
agree with me
um I I think that there were some good
portions when it came to Criminal
Justice Reform but in the larger
conversation here coddling criminals is
a bad idea the the to the point that
like the issue here isn't that they
haven't found out that there are social
services that can help them the issue is
that we are not taking the steps
necessary to make communities safers to
stop crime and to effectively prosecute
individuals when they do commit a crime
there is a difference between a serving
a life sentence for a first-time drug
offense and also continuously
shoplifting vandalizing and destroying
neighborhoods right the the justice
system is supposed to be blind and
balanced and there are certainly
conversations about how it is neither
but to not prosecute criminals is
absolutely insane and then to try and
say that it's now the CVS employee's job
to de-escalate the situation that's like
sending a social worker to like a crime
scene you're you're already in a bad
situation you need to be able to have
law enforcement and prosecutors who help
take care of this because you're not
going to stop crime if people think you
know what I'm gonna get away with it I
think good point I think Professor that
everybody is better at escalating than
de-escalating because we we should be
escalating the problem
why not just like oh you know it's like
wouldn't that be more enjoyable because
I I think everybody's really good at
escalating things yeah so so everybody
who works at a at a CVS now has to be a
trained Golden Gloves boxer yeah right
yeah so not not to be a buzz kill here
but there are three factors that are
predictive of violent crime two of those
are easy to guess their age and sex
overwhelmingly it's male and
overwhelmingly it's between I think it's
six and sixteen but the third factor and
this is the impetus this is the reason
for this it's there's no adult male
present in the home and to a certain
extent neither conservatives nor
liberals for different reasons want to
talk about that so back to your earlier
monologue when you talk about uh uh
crime in the African-American
communities that's not traced to any
racial thing that's traced to the lack
of an adult male in the home so that was
the impetus behind that right right
right and that's and it's interesting
because
but like the conservatives like to bring
that up but there's nothing they can do
about it correct correct there's not
there's outside that when you bring it
up and then the left goes well that's
just racist right because there's no way
like this is a this is a thing that will
never be changed I guess it's just yeah
and that's the that's the problem with
identity politics is you have to have
someone who looks like the members of
the affected Community bring up the
criticism of the people in effect
community so that's why I guess you'd
have to have Golden Gloves block boxers
who are all different kinds of races yes
at CVS yeah and even Fox security I
think they would make it nice I think
they would make I think they need to
make all the drugstores look better
they're very depressing do you ever go
into CVS or Walgreens I just feel very
sad when I go in there that's because
you're not at the kiosk yeah I have not
at the kiss it's also because I'm
picking up a prescription and if I'm
picking up a prescription I'm in a lousy
mood well that went over well
probably should end this segment here
huh well let's keep talking hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else